this Florida man just asked a bank to
print out a document hacked it and
ordinarily went home yep Florida again
his name is vasil savu and he stole 32
000 from the business and tried to do it
a second time how did he do that just
walked into the Western Union asked the
cashier to print out his flight
itinerary from his USB the cashier
plugged the USB into the computer
without a hesitation and located the
file he wanted that's when the virus was
being installed and it
he began to malfunction a few days later
the cashier complained to the owner that
the cursor was moving on its own the
owner searched the computer and found
several fraudulent transactions savvu
tried to do the same at another place
but got recognized and caught now he
remains jailed on a 75 000 Bond yeah
funny story interesting what else
Florida men can do